مصيبه مستوطنان اسرائيليان بجروح في عمليه
اطلاق نار قرب بؤره الاستيطانيه بضاحيه
سلوان العمليه التي يعقبه اخرى خلفت سبعه
قتلى بين المستوطنين في حي الفيعقوب
الاستيطاني اثارت ردود فعل الاقليميه
ودوليه من بينها اعراب الرئيس الامريكي جو
بيدن ياهو قبيله زياره قريبه لبنك المنطقه
عن دعم واشنطن لتل ابيب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر
بعد الاجتياحات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
الدميه للضفه الغربيه وكيف يبدو تعامل
البيت الابيض وهو الذي يقوده حمله
دبلوماسيه كيف يتعامل مع تطورات الوضع
الامنيه في المنطقه في ظل اسرار حكومه
ثانيه على سياساتها وما قادت اليه من ردود
فعل الفلسطينيه وما مدى فرص واشنطن
والمجتمع الدولي في فرض التهدئه والاحتكام
الى ترتيبات جديده بالنظر الى تركيبته
واجدده الحكومه الاسرائيليه والواقع
الجديد الذي صنعته ممارسته
[موسيقى]
عمليه ثانيه فلسطينيه
من دماء الفلسطينيين في مخيم جنين واثاره
العمليتان الفلسطينيتان ردود فعل واسعه
اقليميا ودوليا في وقت تنتظر فيه المنطقه
زياره اخرى لمسؤول امريكي
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بين يمين
نتنياهو وصف عمليه تنفي يعقوب بكونها
الهجوم الاقصى ومن اصعب ما مرت به اسرائيل
في السنوات الاخيره
وتناقلت الاخبار انه يعتزم اعتماد اجراءات
من بينها ترحيله عائلات منفذ العمليات
وارساله تعزيزات العسكريه الى الضفه
وتسهيل الحصول على رخص حمل السلاح
للاسرائيليين رئيس الامريكي صار على
الاتصال بنتنياهو واعرب بيض على استعداد
واشنطن لتقديم كل وسائل الدعم الاسرائيل
مع التشديد على الالتزام بامن اسرائيل
والتواصل المستمر مع قادتها واعتباره
الهجوم يعقوب هجوما على العالم المتحرر
بدوره اعرب الاتحاد الاوروبي وعن دعمه
لاسرائيل وحث على العوده للتنسيق بين رام
الله وتل ابيب داعيا للقياده الاسرائيليه
الى جعل اللجوء لاستخدام القوه المميته
الخيار الاخير
واجديهم بالذكر ان مجلس الامن عقد مجلس
مشاورات بشان تطورات في المنطقه قالت
الصين ان المجلس اخفق في اتخاذ اي قرار
بخصوصها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم للنقاش في هذا الموضوع معنا من
تل ابيب الدكتور دان شفتان رئيسه مركز
دراسات الامن القومي بجامعه حيفا اهلا
وسهلا سيد شفتان اجراءات جديده يعتزم
الرئيس الرئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بنيامين نتنياهو اتخاذها في الاجتماع
اجتماع الحكومه المصغره اليوم ما الذي
ستحذفه من اثر سواء على الاسرائيليين او
على الشعب الفلسطيني
الاثر سيكون قصه طويله بعباره اخرى انا لا
اظن ان هناك حل للارهاب الفلسطيني فنحن
نواجهه منذ 100 عام لا اعتقد انه سيتوقف
له 100 عام من القادمه نحن واجهناه قبل
اقامه دوله اسرائيل وبعض قام بدور اسرائيل
وقبل يونيو 67 وبعد 67 قبل وصله وبعد وصله
الفلسطينيين يحاولون قتل اليهود وكل
الابطال الذين نزل الفلسطينيين هم من
يقتلوا اليهود لاعتقد ان هذا سيتغير ومعظم
اسرائيل اين يفهم ان هذا لن يتغير احيانا
هذا الشعور يقوى او يضعف لكن القياس
الحقيقي هو استمرار الاسرائيلي في حياتهم
الطيبه رغم الارهاب اسرائيل تزداد قوته
واسرائيل اسرائيل لديها طيب ليه مواطنيها
وهذا الارهابي الفلسطيني
يعرقل هذه الحياه بعض الفاينه والاخرى هذه
حقيقه حياتيه
يعني طبعا الارهاب الفلسطيني حسب تعبيرك
انت طبعا السرديه الفلسطينيه وربما
السرديه العالميه مختلفه في توصيف ما يجري
لانه هنالك توصيف قانوني دولي انما يجري
هو دفاع عن النفس لان الفلسطينيين الشعب
يقع تحت قائلته وطائله الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لكن هذه العمليات الفلسطينيه
التي تجري بين الفيله والاخرى ولم تحدث اي
اثرا في المجتمع الاسرائيلي كما تقول اذا
كيف نبرر المظاهرات
والذين رفعوا الشعارات تلوم هذه الحكومه
تلوم بالغفير وجناحها لمتشدد على ما وصلت
اليه الاوضاع الامنيه
ده انت بتتفرج الفلسطيني
احتلال وبعد الاحتراق بعض اعتقد ان احفادي
واحفادي
احفاظ سوف يعليهم ان يقاتلوا مع من يحاول
القتلهم في غزه حتى هم لا يتظاهرون باي
تسويه هم يريدون قتل اليهود هذا من
المسلمات وسوف نتعامل معه
يعني يمكن ان ينتهي ذلك كله بانهاء
الاحتلال اليس كذلك لو انهي الاحتلال
الفصائل الفلسطينيه جميعها مستعده للتعامل
مع حدود 67
نار نار هذا ليس صحيحا حماس تقول بكل
يريدون قتل اليهود ليس فقط لاسرائيل هم
يقولون حتى بعد سحاب اسرائيل من غزه
نحن حصلنا على 90% وخمسه
ثم سنحصل على 100% لماذا علينا ان نتنازل
اذا ما ضحىنا
بهذا لم يعودوا يصدق بكثره فلسطينيه
يريدون حدوث 67 حتى لو كنت محتر وانت لست
محققا
فان الغالبيه
الاسرائيليين سيمظون قدما لان
الصراع ليس على 67 بل هو على حدود
42 لهذا الصدر سوف تستمر لان اسرائيل قويه
لذره والعرض ضعفاء لدرجه تجعلها قادره على
ان تعيش لمده 500 عام مع هذه المشكله قد
يكون هناك ازعاج لكن اسرائيليه
ورؤساء حكومه سابقون تحدثوا عن زواج دوله
اسرائيل لانها لم تعمر ابدا بعد 85 عاما
في تاريخها وها هي في هذه المرحله لا لكن
بلغي خير وزير الامن القومي
اليمين المتشدد في الحكومه يقول امر بانه
امر بمضاعف هذه القوى العامله بقسم
الاسلحه الناريه وتوفير السلاح لمزيد من
المدنيين رد العالم ما وصفه بالارهاب
وطالب بانشاء الحرس الوطني والتجهيزه كقوه
وقائيه وهجوميه كبيره
هل هل كل هذه الاجراءات يمكن ان تحدث فارغ
انت تقول لا شيء سيحدث خارقا فلما كل هذه
الاجراءات اذا
هذا الفلسطيني يستمر ولان هذا هو
النموذج الوحيد والقدوه
ما تعتبره انت ارهابا وما يعتبره
الفلسطينيون حرب دفاعا وتحرير هل هذه
الاجراءات ستمنع اي شيء
دي اكشن هذه الاسعار ستجعل من الصعوبه
اكثر على
الارهابي الفلسطيني نحن دمرنا وحطمنا
الانتفاضه الثانيه بالقوه وقللنا من
الارهاب
98% من خلال التحطيمه وهذه المره سوف
تساعد هذه الاجراءات لكن لن تزيلها لان
الاسرائيلين المسلحين هم غيروا الوضعيه
وفكره انه يسمح
للاسرائيليين المسؤولين
ان يحملوا السلاحف جيدا هل ستزيل الارهابي
الفلسطيني بالكامل كلا واجهناه لمده 100
عام لا نستطيع انهاءه لكن ممكن ان نقلله
من معدلات غير مقبوله الى معدلات لا اقول
مقبول لكن قابله للتعايش معها
علوم في اسرار تتطور اسرائيل علومها صحتها
وكل شيء يقوى رغم الارهاب الفلسطيني ولو
ان الفلسطيني يريدون ان يكون ارهابيين
لمده 100 عام لا باسفيه ذلك نستطيع
التعامل
الوقت نشكر ذلك شفتان رئيس مركز دراسات
الامن القومي بجامعه حيفا من تل ابيب
ولتعميق النقاش معنا من عمان الكاتب
والباحث الفلسطيني وعين الطائر
الدوليه بمركز الدراسات عبر القتل بسيدو
جوزيف وابدا بك سيد جوزيف واختلاف يعني
اللغه لغه الخطاب الامريكي ما بين ما وقع
للفلسطينيين في جنين لغه الخطاب الامريكي
تتحدث عن ضبط النفس تتحدث عن عدم التصعيد
التزام كل الاطراف كل الاطراف لعدم
التصعيد مع ان الفلسطينيين لم يكونوا اي
طرف التصعيد في هذه في مواجهه جنين في
مجزره جنين لكن حينما وق عمليه نيفيا
يعقوب التي قتل فيها سبعه اسرائيليين
الخطاب من الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان
هذا هجوم على العالم المتحضر يعني الهجوم
على جنين لم يكن هجوما على العالم المتحضر
نعم السلام عليكم
سؤال مهم طرحتوه يتطرق الى الوضع الراهن
ومدى صعوبه الوضع وموقف اداره بايرن هي
النقطه التي تنطلق منها في هذا النقاش ان
اداره العمل الارهابيه يوم امس في القدس
شانها شان الدول الاوروبيه وايضا سوف اذكر
دول عربيه اود ان لا اذكر الدول العربيه
كي لا يؤدي الى مشاكل ولكن نحن نعرف ان
دوله عربيه دانت هذه الهجمات لماذا
قاموا بادانه الهجوم في القدس
وليس والعمليه في جنين لان النظر مختلف
هذه النقطه اداره الدول الاوروبيه وحتى في
منطقه في الخليج النظره هي اننا نتحدث عن
حادثين او حدثين منفصلين نحن نتحدث عن
عمليه في جنين يرونها على انها عمليه
للحمايه نتحدث عن عمليه في وضحي النهار
هذا غير اعتياديه بالنسبه الى الاسراء
الاليين ويمكن ان يقتل الجنود الاسرائيلي
لماذا لماذا تقوم اسرائيل بذلك وتعرض حياه
الجنود الاسرائيليين للخطر لو لم يكن هناك
اي حادث خطر وطبعا ماساه ان امراه
فلسطينيه قتلت ويجب ان تتحمل المسؤوليه
الجهه المسؤوله ولكن العمليه بحد ذاتها
مختلفه عن ما حصل في القدس وهذا ما اشار
اليه الرئيس والجهات الاخرى نحن نتحدث هنا
عن ارهاب ولسوء الحظ بالنسبه الى
الفلسطينيين
تحتفل بهذا الامر هو ان يتم وضع الى جانب
الارهابيين وليس الى جانب الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي وليس فقط
اسرائيل بل كل الدول التي تعرف الفرق نحن
نعرف ما هو السبب والفكره التي اشار اليها
الضيف السابق اوضح من خلالها هذه النقاط
اتحدث عن الدول العربيه التي ااه ادانت
عمليه يعقوب مصر والامارات ادانتها همم
لكن ايضا تحدثت عن الاتحاد الاوروبي سيد
جوزيف الاتحاد الاوروبي على لسان جوز
باريل منسق الشؤون الخارجيه للاتحاد تحدث
عما فعله الاسرائيليون ايضا في الضفه
الغربيه قال ان الاسرائيليين قتلوا
الثلاثين الفلسطينيا منذ هذا الشهر منذ
بدايه هذا الشهر في عمليات في الضفه
الغربيه قال ان همم ان ان اسرائيل قتلت
مئه وخمسين فلسطينيه العام الماضي في
الضفه الغربيه بينهم 30 طفلا وان هذا لا
يمكن ان يساعد في احلال السلام لماذا
يختلف الموقف الامريكي عن ذلك لماذا لا
يتحدث الموقف الامريكي ابدا عن القتل
الفلسطينيين
نعم اعتقد ان هذه النقطه عادله وسؤال مهم
للغايه اود ان اقول ان كل حاله من هذه
الحالات الثلاثين التي ادت الى مقتل
فلسطيني باضافه الى العام الماضي كل حادثه
هي ماساه ولكن ليست كل حادثه نتيجه عمليه
اسرائليه غير قانونيه البعض منها قد يكون
كذلك البعض من البعض من ال 30 ولكن
الاكثريه لا اعرف الرقم بشكل محدد نحن
نعرف ان الاكثريه ليست نتيجه عمليات غير
قانونيه من جانب اسرائيل ليست قتلا عمد من
قبل الاسرائيليين بل في جنين على سبيل
المثال يبدو ان
الحادث ادى الى مقتلي ناشطين مسلحين كانوا
يتحاضرون لقتل الاسراء وانا اود ان استمع
الى الضيف الاخر همم
والمحلل الفلسطيني انا همم اود ان استمع
الى رايه كذلك ولكن اذا ما كنتم كف
فلسطينيين ترفضون الوجود الاسرائيليه
والوجود اليهودي بشكل جذري في ما تعتاد ما
تعتبرونه فلسطين بما في ذلك دوله اسرائيل
اذا ما رفضتم ذلك بالتالي بالفعل نفسه ما
من شيء
يقول ان العمليه غير قانونيه الاسرائيليه
يوم امس استمعت الى متحدث وقال وهجم
الاسرائيلين طبعا اليهود كانوا في تلك
المنطقه
للالف من السنوات ولم ياتوا دخل الى
المنطقه وبالتالي اذا ما كانت هذه النظره
الى اسرائيل والى الاسرائيلي اذا بالفعل
نفسه اي قرار او فعل تاخذه اسرائيل هو
جورمي حتى عندما تقتل الارهابيين الذين
يخططون لقتل الاسرائيليين هذه هي النقطه
الاساسيه واريد ان استمع الى الضيف الاخر
وانا ايضا استمع الى الاستاذ والكاتبه
والباحث الفلسطيني وعين الطاهر وتحدث
ضيفنا عن امور كثيره من واشنطن تحدث عن
همم الوجود التاريخي لليهود في فلسطين همم
تحدث عن الاذانات العربيه للعمليات
الفلسطينيه همم كيف نفهم المواقف العربيه
فيما يتعلق بهذه العمليه
انا ما اعتقد ان ضيفك من واشنطن لا يختلف
في موقفه كثيرا عن الذي تحدث من داخل
الارض الفلسطينيه المحتله
كلاهما ينطلق من ذات الرؤيا من رؤيه
صهيونيه او منحازل الصهيونيه على اي حال
لن ادخل في سجل حول هذا الموضوع ولكن
لعل ضيفك من واشنطن قد اصاب في نقطه واحده
وهي ان السرديه الفلسطينيه تختلف جذريا عن
السرديه الصهيونيه
الفلسطينيون يعتقدون برواياتهم التاريخيه
انهم اصحاب الحق التاريخي في فلسطين وهذا
شيء يؤكده التاريخ وتاكده حتى
المؤرخون الاسرائيليون الجدد الذين لم
يجدوا اي اثر يشير الى وجود همم
همم
لاسرائيليين على مدى العصور السابقه نحن
هنا نتحدث كا كباحثين
وكمحللين همم ما حدث في فلسطين هو استعمار
استيطامي كولونيالي احلالي
نقطه واضحه لكل المشاهدين العرب لكن نريد
ان نفهم الان همم هذا الوضع الذي نحن فيه
الان الى اي اتجاه سيصير هيك هل سيسير الى
الوضع الى تصعيد مزيد من التصعيد الى
مواجهه شامله همم ام يمكن احتوائه
يعني نعم انا اظن في الحقيقه ان هذا هو
الموقف الامريكي والموقف الاوروبي كلا
موقفين
ينطلقان من
محاوله احتواء الاوضاع وليس حلها
الموقف الامريكي الرسمي يتحدث عن حل
الدولتين وكذلك الموقف الاوروبي
ولكنهما في الحقيقه لم يبذو راي جهد فعلي
لتفكيك الاحتلال لاجلاء الاحتلال لتفكيك
الاستيطان والعكس عندما يحدث توتر يتوجه
الضغط نحو السلطه الفلسطينيه
لاحتواء الموقف كما هي في تصريحات جو
بايتن انا اريد ان اعود بالتاريخ يعني
قليلا الى الوراء ليذكر بموقف الرئيس
الامريكي جورج بوش عندما لوح بوقف
المساعدات الامريكيه على اسرائيل ليجبر
اسحاق امير رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي على
الذهاب الى مؤتمر
ما يحدث هو ان الغرب نعم
تسمح لي يا استاذ معين واعتذر للمقاطعه
اريد ان اسال عنها ضيفي من واشنطن ادوار
جوزيف ونحن ننتظر زياره يعني نترقد زياره
ابلنكل للمنطقه همم ما الذي يحمله ما الذي
سيقوله للاسرائيليين على سبيل المثال
بالضبط
ولكن اقول انني امل انه سوف يقول التالي
امل انه سوف يتحدث مع الرئيس محمود عباس
كذلك بالاضافه الى رئيس مجلس الوزراء
نتانيا
وامل وتوقع ان يقول ذلك اسمعوا انا اعرف
انه ما من حل لذلك الان واداره الرئيس لن
تحاول
همم التوصل الى
سلا من شامل طبعا هو الحل ولكن الوزير
يعرف
الديناميات السياسيه
الداخليه حتى اصدقاء فلسطيني يقررون بذلك
الفلسطيني
هناك انقسام بين حماس والسلطه الفلسطينيه
بقياده الرئيس
الذي
انقساما كذلك في الساحه الساحه
الاسرائيليه حتى داخل اليمين نفسه نشكرك
شكرا جزيلا من واشنطن المدير التنفيذي
لمعهد الشؤون الدوليه بمركز الدراسات عبر
الاطلس
وايضا نشكر ضيفنا من عمان الكاتب والباحث
الفلسطيني
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج مراد الخبر
[موسيقى]